all right let's spend a few minutes
today talking about a new blockchain
project that's doing some interesting
things in their space called mone this
video was sponsored by mone we also
interviewed mone co-founder Martin era
vets last week which you can check out
in our video feed so let's start with
some background just to get some context
about what mone is doing mone is dealing
with what is called the peer-to-peer
economy and when I say peer-to-peer I'm
talking about transactions or activities
between people who interact directly
with one another and this is in contrast
to a centralized model so peer-to-peer
would be like you selling something to
someone you know without first selling
it to a third party who then sells it to
the buyer or without even a third party
kind of being a middleman in that
transaction and there's many situations
that seem peer-to-peer like when you buy
something on eBay when you buy something
directly from another person or not from
eBay itself but eBay acts as the
intermediary it's not really
peer-to-peer in that strict sense and in
many situations there are benefits to
having a middleman and using a
centralized model when you're using
Airbnb to rent something somewhere to
stay or you're using Craigslist to buy a
service those are some examples of when
a middleman or intermediary can be
useful but there are cost to doing
business through intermediaries one is
you forfeit a certain amount of your
privacy many companies that facilitate
transactions are collecting data about
you another is that there can be a lack
of transparency we don't know how a lot
of these intermediaries are operating we
don't know if everything they're doing
is completely fair to the users or how
much information they collect about us
or any number of things that a user
might benefit from knowing which the
centralized platform may not want you to
know about another reality is the cost
obviously when you use a lot of these
services some take a flat fee some take
a percentage of the transaction some are
in other ways making money off of the
service that they provide which in most
cases is a cost that gets passed on to
the user in one way or another even if
it's not totally obvious how that's
one type of attempt to decentralize
these models and fix these issues has
been to implement public block chains
like Bitcoin or aetherium based
infrastructures but those solutions also
have some inherent inefficiencies for
these types of uses they require every
node in the blockchain network around
the world to process everyone's commands
this paradigm still requires users to
interact with that public blockchain in
the same way they would interact with
other online services the actual
computation and management of data is
left to somebody else
Monay sees peer-to-peer activities
facilitated through centralized third
parties and public block chains to be
paradoxical and not actually truly
peer-to-peer because users aren't just
purely interacting with one another
they're still dealing with these
downsides as a result of intermediaries
what Monet is trying to put in place as
a solution as an alternative to these
client-server models is a system in
which people interact and work and carry
out transactions with one another in a
more actually authentically peer-to-peer
manner this would be done through what
they call mobile ad hoc block chains
basically these would be temporary
miniature block chains where people's
actual mobile devices are the nodes on
the network the network is only as big
as the number of people interacting and
the nodes are only connected for as long
as the users are wanting to interact and
the small block chain that's established
between the nodes the mobile devices of
the users themselves is essentially
playing the role that a central server
played in the traditional model users
don't have to trust a third party they
don't have to delegate work to a third
party as is the case in a centralized
model and the users are only connected
to who they need to be connected to
based on their geographical location
users don't have to stay online to
support other users as is the case in a
large decentralized network which Monet
sees as inefficient for these
peer-to-peer applications and where
Monet is a platform and company comes in
is build
maintaining open source software kits
that let developers build the blockchain
consensus technology into their apps
it's a really fascinating project
conceptually several mechanisms coming
into play in ways that we haven't seen
before also make it more interesting and
as far as blockchain on mobile devices
and how that's being implemented I'm
looking forward to seeing how it follows
up how they follow up and continuing to
discuss it this video is sort of part 1
of 2 video overviews I'll be doing about
Monet so stay tuned for part 2 where I
will go more in depth about how the
platform works and again check out my
interview with Monet's co-founder martin
era vets you can find out even more
about monet by going to monet dot
network i've put a link below underneath
this video